a long line many here hoping they will
not be in the car that pulls up when the
water runs out come back tomorrow ma'am
at five o'clock and we'll have bigger
bottles of water thank you ma'am i am so
sorry
the capital of mississippi has a long
troubled water treatment plant now
knocked off line by recent flooding for
many the taps are dry for those who have
water it is simply unsafe
it's a hurting feeling when you don't
have no water
you know especially when you got newborn
babies say hey he smiled
residents are being told to boil their
water to wash dishes and to keep their
mouths closed in the shower
the city council president tells al
jazeera
this is not a new problem
for the past two years there has not
been a month
where citizens in south jackson has not
gone a weekend or two days
or even sometimes a week with either low
flow or no flow no flow and had to have
a boil water notes
the unfortunate thing about it is
that this is becoming somewhat of a norm
mississippi's largest city is more than
80 percent black and some residents
believe that is why the city's water
system has been neglected for decades
we are seeing the intentional divestment
in communities that are led by black
elected officials
i am going to have a black son
and to have a city that has poor schools
poor roads
you know
grocery stores running out of food
and
no water to drink i honestly don't even
want to bathe my baby in jackson's water
and it doesn't appear the quality is
going to get better anytime soon
our immediate priority is to have
running water
even temporarily sacrificing
some quality standards where we
absolutely have to
to fulfill basic sanitary and safety
needs
a long time problem now an acute crisis
in the sweltering heat of a mississippi
summer a dangerous one as well
patti culhane al jazeera